from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between wendy's in the uk and the us
this is food wars
in the uk wendy's iconic frosties come
in three sizes junior regular and large
in the us we actually have four frosty
sizes junior small medium large
we're going to pour out the largest
frosty to see how big it is compared to
the
the us's hamburger at a wendy's is
called a dave's named after the founder
dave thomas ours come in singles doubles
and triples our burgers are the same in
the uk they also come as singles doubles
or triples now we're gonna weigh a u.s
triple
pretty close 14 ounces for our triple
now while the triple might be the
official limit on burger sizes at
wendy's wendy's enthusiasts have come up
with something called a meat cube this
is a secret menu item where you actually
take an extra meat patty and add it to
this so you get four patties which i
think adds up to around a pound joe i'm
officially challenging you to a meat
cube showdown the fastest person to eat
the entire meatkeep wins you think you
got it i accept your challenge harry
let's do this three
and one start
[Music]
i see where the triple is the limit now
time 107. i wish i had more time to chew
it
need the sauce
need some moisture
the buns
[Music]
usa baby
ah terrible
i feel absolutely terrible and yet
elated that i won well now we know why
the u.s has such an obesity problem
okay that's quite enough of that
back to our regularly scheduled
programming another iconic wendy's menu
item is the baconator in the uk these
just come in one size as a regular of
course in the us we also have the
baconator but we have a smaller
baconator known as the son of baconator
something incredibly unsettling about a
burger having a child that's also a
burger this baconator giving birth to
that baconator and of course we're gonna
weigh the regular baconators to see
whose is bigger the highly regarded
wendy's nuggets that come in regular or
spicy love the spicy they come in units
of four six and ten
nuggets in the uk only come in two
portion sizes four and eight
wendy's of course has fries and those
fries in the us come in four sizes
junior small medium large our fries also
come in four sizes value small medium
and large let's wear our large fries to
see who's getting more
ours is way less
what's that all about
another side that is probably unique to
wendy's i can't think of any other fast
food place that does this is wendy's
chili it has been on the menu since it
opened back in 1969.
in the u.s you can get your chili
for whatever reason in two sizes small
and large in the uk we only have one
size of chili which is this one we're
going to weigh it against the largest
size in the us to find the difference
finally let's compare drinks in the u.s
you can get three sizes of drink small
medium and large on the internet it does
not specify
how much fluid ounces are in any of
these
i've had to guess
too much way too much
way way too much in the uk drinks come
in three sizes small medium or large and
these are advertised as being 12 16 and
20 ounces respectively let's measure the
larger strengths to see which countries
is bigger
so our large drink actually came out as
close to 18 ounces than closer to 20. i
will say that in the uk you fill up your
own drink so maybe i just needed to fill
a bit more okay so their large is 18
ounces what is our small
20 ounces so our small is bigger than
their large
man we love drinking our calories in
this country we'll love drinking our
calories
for this episode we thought it might be
fun to compare some prices from wendy's
in the uk and the u.s let's use this
baconator as a basis for comparison in
the u.s a baconator on its own no combo
would cost 7.39
the same burger in the uk will cost you
six pounds 29 which at the time of
recording this was around 8.90 which is
a 20 increase however if you were to
turn this into a medium combo yes this
is the medium
the price would go up to 11.19 whereas
in the uk adding a baconator to a combo
meal will only increase the price to
seven pounds and nine pence so actually
the us meal is now eleven percent more
expensive whoa whoa whoa harry don't get
ahead of yourself wendy's in the us has
an ace up its sleeve the four for four
promotion
you can get your choice of a junior
bacon cheeseburger a junior cheeseburger
seen here a double stack or a crispy
chicken sandwich along with junior fries
four nuggets and a value drink all of
this four bucks
sadly wendy's has not replicated that
deal here in the uk not even in the form
of a four for four pounds deal if you
were to buy all the components of a us
four for four dollars here in the uk it
would cost you six pounds 36 which is
about nine dollars that's 125 increase
on the u.s price the real damage here is
done by the nuggets which cost 2 pounds
99 on their own in the uk that's around
4.24 cents aka more than the entire 404
combo in the us so it looks like the us
provides more value if you're a little
smart about what you order and how you
order it
say you walk into a us wendy's you want
to get the baconator combo meal just how
unhealthy is it you ask well i will tell
you okay the burger 960 calories fries
360 calories and the drink medium right
coke okay it's gonna be 370 calories
this whole shebang
1690 calories that's 84 of your daily
allowance what about the same meal here
in the uk well our baconator is actually
more calorific because it comes in at
1010 calories however the fries are just
239 calories and the coke just 200
leaving the total at 1449.
that's a 16 decrease from the us what
you ask is the most calorific thing on
the wendy's us menu it is this burger in
front of me the pretzel bacon pub triple
look at this thing
goodness
1520 calories 106 grams of fat 45 of
those grams are saturated that's 135
of your daily fat allowance sadly that's
the us exclusive and our most calorific
item is actually just the dave's triple
in the uk one of these is 1204 calories
with 81 grams of fat of which 33 grams
are saturated
thankfully wendy's discloses a full
ingredients list for both the uk and the
us so let's take a closer look at some
of the menu items right now here is
everything that's in a wendy's baconator
in the uk drop in because this is a long
ingredient section premium bun wheat
flour water sugar yeast mayonnaise
rapeseed oil 78
water ketchup tomatoes 148 grams
american cheese slice cheese 70
milk beef patty 100 beef bacon sugar
water
table salt salt anti-caking agent sodium
ferrocyanide seems like a lot right well
guess what we got the ukb to get here's
everything in a u.s baconator
start with the premium bun enrich flour
which is wheat flour malted barley flour
niacin reduce iron
sodium
sodium nitrate
that's all of it
now that is a long list is there
anything in there you should be worried
about well we can start with sodium
nitrate which is found in the applewood
smoked bacon sodium nitrate is a
chemical used to cure meats and it gives
them that appealing pig color which is
perfect for bacon also super toxic is
prohibited for sale on certain websites
like ebay because it's been used in
homicide attempts and a dental assistant
once died after eating just a one gram
tablet by mistake thankfully there's
none of that in the uk but just like the
us we do have lecithin in our american
cheese according to some academics there
are a worrisome number of scientific
studies which have suggested that it can
promote depression which is kind of the
last thing that i need
outside of the baconator there are one
or two ingredients you should watch out
for in the pretzel bacon pub burger the
pretzel bun contains potassium chloride
which in normal food doses is fine but
is one of the three ingredients in the
three drug cocktail used for lethal
injection apparently enough of it would
cause an abnormal heartbeat and cardiac
arrest let's be honest if anything in
this burger is stopping your heart it's
going to be the cholesterol and
saturated fat long before the potassium
chloride the pickles also contain
polysorbate 80. now this is commonly
used as an emulsifier in some foods but
with pickles it's used as a solubilizer
which means that it helps other
ingredients dissolve in the brine
the bad news is studies have suggested
that it can cause colon cancer in mice
yikes
here's everything you find at a wendy's
in the uk that you won't find in the u.s
and here is everything
you get a u.s wendy's you can't get in
the uk
this is ridiculous
let's start with the burgers now as far
as i can tell we only have three
exclusive burgers one of which i'm not
even sure is an exclusive burger which
is this one the cheeseburger deluxe the
reason i'm not sure if it's an exclusive
is because in the us you guys have
something called a junior cheeseburger
deluxe which looked very similar to this
and i just wanted to check if
what you guys considered junior we
considered deluxe over here yes harry
they look pretty similar the only
difference i could find is that ours has
ketchup and mayo and yours has sauce so
i guess it boils down to whatever your
sauce is next up we got this one which
is the veggie stack it's a vegetarian
exclusive there's definitely some like
corn in there
some kind of like black bean kidney bean
thing maybe some carrot and pepper
[Music]
it's not for me but i am a die-hard
carnivore so maybe those vegetarians out
there who appreciate this a lot more our
final exclusive sandwich is this one the
avocado chicken club oh my goodness we
have so much to go through i guess i
will start with the
burgers um
here is something called the bourbon
bacon cheeseburger maybe a bourbon
barbecue sauce something for wendy's
burger aficionados the pretzel bacon pub
cheeseburger i think it comes in one two
or three stacks this is the three
stacker okay the double stack
which is uh two patties cheese bacon a
junior hamburger junior hamburger small
this is for the kids
junior cheeseburger deluxe oh yeah
lettuce onion tomato pickles
there it is the big fake and classic
okay so they went to the chicken all
right chicken goodies the asiago ranch
chicken sandwich okay this is the
jalapeno popper sandwich
the pretzel bun bacon
pub sandwich crispy chicken blt sandwich
looks to be what a blt would be with the
little chicken guy in there
so spicy nuggets mentioned before and
spice is way better than regulars
then we have a couple of exclusive salad
options in the uk i'm usually pretty
suspicious of fast food salads but i've
got to say these actually do look pretty
good the first exclusive salad i wanted
to show you was the avocado veggie salad
however i think they got the order mixed
up and gave me an avocado chicken salad
instead so what i was supposed to get
was this salad which contains avocado
and then instead of the chicken and
bacon we're supposed to get some of the
veggie bites that mixed up in there
instead and then the second exclusive
salad is this one this is the apple
cranberry chicken salad you know it's a
good salad when they give you the
dressing and some other ecu
on the side instead of just jumbling it
all up and then like letting it get
soggy we got four salads then jalapeno
popper again the chicken the bacon
jalapenos cheese
taco salad
wait is there any
there's no ground beef on this there's
no meat on this it's like what you would
put on tacos at home shredded cheese
shredded lettuce cut up tomatoes next
salad apple pecan salad the summer
strawberry salad
oh
chicken bacon strawberries yeah okay we
have one other exclusive veggie option
which is this one
these are veggie bites now these are a
vegetarian alternative to wendy's
chicken nuggets just judging from kind
of the look and
smell of them i think they're made from
probably a very similar blend to the
veggie stack burger
and for that reason i probably won't try
and eat one it looks like falafel but
just smells and feels way worse
i love falafel
the pub fries
yes who hasn't been in a pub getting a
pint with the lads
man they're really pushing strawberries
this summer wendy's and the salad i got
these two things equals a lot to me i
also got to think of apple slices
i don't know if this is a solo side i
don't know why we have apple slices if
you need something to dip your veggie
bites or anything else into then we have
a couple of exclusive sauce options as
well
sauce talk we'll start with this one
which is a garlic mayo and then our
other exclusive sauce is this one which
is a part of heinz sweet chili we love
sweet chilli sauce here in the uk i
don't know why but it's just offered by
like a lot of big fast food chains i got
a whole bag here
dipping sauces
buttermilk ranch
ooh
creamy sriracha
side of sauce
something called the hot
chili seasoning
we also have a few exclusive breakfast
items from the uk wendy's starting with
this one which is just an egg and cheese
breakfast sandwich i'm sure they would
make you one of these in the us if you
asked but it's actually a default menu
item in the uk whereas it didn't look
like it was one in the us then true to
form for the uk we have three different
porridge options for breakfast we have
plain porridge add some jam to it they
give you a little sachet of jam and you
squeeze that into your porridge and
finally probably the most exciting
porridge option which is this one is the
cranberry seed porridge there's a lot of
breakfast sandwiches to go through so
let's give it a shot i'll just go down
the line here maple bacon
chicken croissant sandwich everything's
square with wendy's
sausage egg and cheese biscuit
bacon egg and cheese biscuit
sausage biscuit yeah these are always
like
it's just it really is just the sausage
patty and a biscuit like can you think
of something drier to have in the
morning breakfast burrito this thing is
ice cold i'm sorry wendy's i did not
mean to misrepresent your breakfast
burrito i'm sure it's great
this thing it's like
geez louise
oh no i don't know what this is
chicken biscuit
biscuit and fried chicken and nothing
else
the wendy's the u.s you can get a cold
brew iced coffee a vanilla frosty chino
and a chocolate frostino now we have a
few exclusive drinks in the uk but
they're pretty much all hot drinks now
it looked like in the us you guys can
get the very basic kind of filter coffee
or you can get the frosty chinos and
stuff like that whereas in the uk we
have a whole range of espresso drinks
you can get things like lattes and
cappuccinos as well as some breakfast
teas
they have a bunch of lemonades one has
an n on it is this the all-natural
lemonade it is wow and this lemonade's
really good strawberry lemonade is
excellent man wendy's with the
strawberries this year pineapple mango
oh yeah
tropical connor tropical i bet it's a
tropical berry
good drinks
now also i'm looking for a flashing
fruit punch an iced tea and a sweet iced
tea and for desserts at wendy's and get
yourself an oatmeal bar
chocolate chunk cookie
and last and not least
sugar cookie
night ladies and gentlemen
is it
we're done cut
dude
it'd be so funny if i threw up in the
middle of this if i had to puke i'm not
gonna say anything i'm gonna barf right
on the desk
i'm not putting that shirt back on i'm
too hot ugh